despite widespread international
condemnation Israel remains largely
unapologetic about the thousands injured
and more than a hundred killed by its
soldiers along the border with Gaza my
guest this week here in Jerusalem is
Michael Oren Deputy Minister for public
affairs his government rejects any
external investigation into the Gaza
violence what's it got to fear
[Music]
Michael Aaron welcome to conflict zone
good to be with ich Tim you said in a
radio interview on the 16th of May your
army had no choice but to use live fire
against Palestinians on the Gaza side of
your border because two days earlier our
soldiers you said came under intensive
fire from those Hamas terrorists
what kind of fire mr. Oher intense fire
intense fire vehicles submachine gun and
grenades and and roadside bombs but
that's not the only reason our soldiers
opened fire the principal reason was
that there was a threat to the border
and the soldiers are charged with
defending our border from terrorists and
civilians who have been driven by
terrorists with the express purpose of
breaking through the border killing our
civilians and destroying our state I
understand this how long did this
intensive fire last I wasn't there I
don't know all right that all it was
long enough for our soldiers it can last
seconds damn casualties thank God but
would you prefer it if they had no one
soldier injured by shrapnel so so
intensive was the focus that not enough
for you would you like some more which
but let me ask a question would you have
preferred that they've broken through
the fence and killed a number of safe
farmers on a kibbutz or the fact is
there was no intensive firing from Hamas
gunmen that there was there and we know
that because by the evening your army
spokesman Jonathan Cahn Rica's said our
troops have not taken any sustained
direct fire and I have information to
the contrary that they were under fire
but that's not misrepresenting the
situation then no I think you are
misrepresenting the situation there
we've had a note from both - no but you
let me let me ask let me let me let me
let me take a different approach let's
just hold on one second now you've asked
me say three four questions about Gaza
there's been one important word missing
from your line of questioning the word
is Hamas Hamas is a terrorist
organization
turns of its geography that theology
it's no different than Isis
it wasn't a totalitarian state
it still has be just dedicated to our
destruction
it still has people it has people who
voted for Hamas by the way but those
people have been driven to despair by
Hamas and then driven to the border in
buses with drivers with guns to their
heads by Hamas told by Hamas I have to
finish to break through the border in
order to kill our civilians and to
destroy our state now ok you want to
take you want to deep conceptualize that
decide whether cancer eyes know what you
want to do is that what's important to
you is it yet to the fact isn't it
strange that Hamas which you said it
declared its intentions to break through
the border to kill Israelis and destroy
your country it offered no sustained
direct fire which would have helped it
to secure those aims I don't follow your
line question they try to cut through
the fence they put bombs along the fence
they threw grenades whether it's across
the fence yeah doesn't that the whole
thing was about the whole program
several several no there's no or 12
different protests again you're very
different from your military spokesman
is that your point I I'm seeing whether
you've got the facts right no I'm seeing
whether you understand anything about
this situation remotely I'm talking
about two people who seem to have very
different views about what actually
happened let me take a different
approach just leave that aside okay
maybe I have a different citation and
besides maybe have a different
reputation that our military
spokesperson because I'm also dealing
with the Gaza issue on the government
level and it's not uncommon in combat
situations to have different reports
what is interesting to me frankly is
that okay now you haven't mentioned
Hamas today that's because that's really
not important to us about Hamas I'm
talking to you but what your forces did
but my forces did cannot be removed and
from the fact that that Gaza is a
terrorist state it can't be I'm going to
come on to your views of God of God
and Hamas but sixty people died than
fifty three of them were terrorists 68
53 of them worked Harry I just get
through the knowledge because you can
train them as a civilian so now you're
gonna have some time to say this okay
good sixty people had that hundreds were
injured because of several attempts to
cross the border several those are your
words no your military spokesman said
seven but there were 12 different flash
points that was the threat to Israel's
way of life several attempts to cross
the border I am NOT the spokesman of our
military spokesman I am the spokes with
the government and I'm a my own
spokesman and I'm telling you there were
dozens of Tempe's to cross the border
and those were the people who were shot
we're presenting in imminent danger to
our border and every shot taken had to
have three clearance orders because we
have eyes on everybody there and we can
see who's cutting through the border and
it is at that distance rubber bullets
are not effective to your gas is not
effective we use lethal fire because
there was no choice and last point if
they had broken through the border many
many more people would have been killed
including a great many more Palestine
but there's no wonder with a different
information we're getting from you and
from your spokesmen that people are
calling for an international objective
investigation which your government is
rejected and we will continue if you've
nothing to hide
the Army's rules have been gaming us for
a Great Britain with the United States
of America would Germany agreed to an
international investigation of its
troops if Germany in the United States
and Great Britain had an internationally
revered and respected judicial system
which had proven again and again capable
of judging itself we're not talking
about them we're talking about Israel no
we're talking about a question see
publish the rules of engagement know the
rules of engagement are public really
perfect by the way you should know I
have an NGOs in court trying to get them
released III actually have problems with
our rules it's all they're classified I
have problems with summer I think that
our rules of engagement are kind of
lenient I
would prefer if you want to get my
opinion on something I think sometimes
the rules of engagement are too lenient
in certain circumstances not necessarily
in this circumstance but we have very
Joseph very straight riled and get those
rules of engagement what they were at
the border what they are still at the
blood I'll tell you Matt we not any
individual who presented a danger to the
border and that danger could not be
interdicted in any other way that person
was then targeted by life are and the
blanket excuse as outlined by your
Defense Minister Avigdor Lieberman on
April the 8th was there are no innocence
in Gaza so it doesn't matter whether
they're armed or posing a threat
nobody's innocent here from Gaza are
they
I said spokesman for my defense ministry
I'm not his spokesman either no no
that's not it's the minister
go if you want to ask the question ask
that of him you know it is it is an
active responsibility in your government
in our political system there actually
isn't politicians come out coming
whenever they want what he says it
doesn't conform with my view but
situation complex their income is
because yes it's controlled by a
terrorist organization which is
committed toward destruction but it was
voted in by the population of of Gaza
now if you had an Israeli government
that made controversial decisions and
I'm sure you may have some problems with
some of those issues made by the Israeli
government you wouldn't say that the
Israeli population or no responsibility
of that because we had democratic
elections and are populated voted for
those popular for those politicians so
you know innocence not essence I think I
prefer to talk about who posed an
imminent threat to the fence because
because Israel Israel alone went to
great lengths to address the
humanitarian situation in Gaza Egypt
closed its borders I will point Israel
has the only High Commissioner for Human
Rights coded a toxic slum the High
Commissioner Haiti for 11 years the High
Commissioner of Human Rights condemns
Israel more frequently than all
countries and the world combined
including Syria even or
reports do you read every one of his
reports not if I have to not know what
he says no I know what the Human Rights
Council said that's different from the
office of the High Commissioner is
really is really awesome but Human
Rights official but he's wrong okay no
he's not he's wrong he's profoundly
wrong
Ezreal had the only three crossings into
Gaza they're called Karen Shalom Carney
and and Eira's Israel alone Hamas
shelled Carney and closed it down
Hamas dug tunnels under Arras and closed
it down
Karen Shalom was still open twelve
hundred truckloads of equipment food
medical supplies went through every day
more than enough to address the
humanitarian situation when everyday up
to three months ago when Hamas burnt it
down and it burnt it down three times it
burnt down the fuel lines into Gaza
Michael Oren now we have more than three
thousand injured we have over another
Israel has a has a blockade of Gaza
which only affects military equipment
and items that can be used it has
affected a lot of things and you know
that as well no I don't and your
Crescent so interesting mmm
can I get some say one word just one
word can we agree on this just one word
say the word Hamas and see what happens
because it's just not in your vocabulary
I tells us about what they do and I'm
talking to you you don't represent Hamas
you represent Volks Minh for use how
much the legitimate organization he
driving red would you rather we didn't
talk to Hamas I think would you talk to
Isis to interview Isis do al Qaeda has
anybody interviewed Isis has anybody
interviewed I called you up and said how
about an interview
absolutely we're finished cutting off a
few heads here and we'd like to we'd
like to talk to absolutely and I would
put everybody through the same process
of tough interview which as you know is
what we do we do this is this is silly
interview there's a big difference you
tough and ridiculous let me tell you why
it's ridiculous look you gotta let me
finish can you take the tough you can
give it up you can't take it you know
we're dealing with a terrorist
organization that is committed to our
destruction that is trying to break the
defense it's not hiding anywhere
it's intention to break the fence the
head of Hamas sin whare said the goal is
to break through the friends kill
Israelis to eat their livers quote
unquote
and since when you trust everything that
Hamas I don't how mas killed a thousand
of my countrymen in this city during the
second think I don't have to worry about
what they say it's what they do and
what's interesting about your mind a
question came you know we're sitting
here in the Knesset it's the only
democratic institution in the Middle
East actually functions we got 15 Arab
members upstairs
stay with the events that nobody think
it's very important to put it in context
you know two hour drive from here today
not two weeks ago today the Syrian army
is moving into the Yarmouk Palestinian
refugee camp it's killing hundreds maybe
thousands of a skewer but I want it this
is what I want to tell you I want to ask
you do you care do you care about any of
those Palestinians I want I want also a
truly innocent Palestine it was we cover
also have you has DW covenant yes DW has
come yes it was I find interesting is
that you're with this line of
questioning about whether I'm on the
same page with a lieutenant colonel in
our spokesman's office absolutely
because you're interested in whether I
agree with everything our defense
minister says but the broader issue of
whether the Jewish state has a right to
defend itself from those who want to
destroy it and whether your television
station or you as a journalist care
about any other Palestinians or any
other Arabs goes to a very deep point
indeed whether you have a problem or
obsessive interest in Jews or whether
you have a racist disinterest in who
kills Arabs when Arabs can I just come
back to asking you about what you did we
have according to UNICEF a thousand
children who have been wounded by
gunfire I want to know what threat those
a thousand children were to the State of
Israel I don't know unless they're being
used as human shields we have very
strict open fire engagement all
if they are being used as human shields
you don't have the right to shoot
children oh you you are the position of
a soldier along our border who is under
a constant hail of stones whose blinded
by smoke that has been put up by Hamas
through burning tires
in order to blind the soldiers and you
see a breach in the fence your one job
as that soldier it's not to worry about
how you're going to look on your
television station your job and that
tells you sir it's to protect the
thousands of Israeli civilians were on
the other side of that border and yes
ironically if the Palestinians had
broken through the fence then the the
the death toll would have been much much
higher on both depends how many broke
through doesn't it but that's an sunny
it has a good hypothetical situation I
think you'd be much more comfortable if
they did break through I think you'd
actually be comfortable they killed a
number of our civilians and killed our
soldiers then we can have some type of
you know something that would make this
morally palatable but in your universe
where everything Israel does because we
are a Jewish state is somehow you you
are you include motives to me because of
the questions I ask I'm I'm a couple of
questions I'm quoting yes I'm quoting
and I have been quoting from your
spokespeople the fact is that despite
you say your justification in opening
fire your military spokesman admitted at
a briefing set up by the Jewish
Federations of North America but it was
a mistake to kill Israel had failed to
minimize the number of casualties he
said that we have tried to be as
accurate as deliberate and as specific
as possible using only sniper rifles so
we've done a lot to try and minimize
casualties have we been successful at it
unfortunately no okay but it begs the
question why why why we're your rules
too permissive or were they illegal no
neither you're setting up a false a
false choice that's our economy so tell
me we don't have means other than at
that distance at that intensity and at
that level of danger
other than the use of lethal force
because the other means have been
exhausted whether it be tear gas or
rubber bullets water cannon firing over
water Aaron is ineffective
firing over people's heads ineffective
obviously because they go through and
they go cuz the snipers those who were
actually given permission to fire go
through a long protocol that includes
using rubber bullets that ludes calling
non-lethal fire and the amount of people
dead and you know fifth member 53 of the
63 we're terrorists by the admission of
the terrorists and was around a move-out
some where I imagine sure you don't know
their bodies were tracked in and if they
know they know but they are so really
we're not many were because our soldiers
came under fire and they yes they came
under intensive fire so that we don't
get lost in the generalizations and
other issues
can we just look at one shooting that
happened on May the 13th it was reported
by a New York Times reporter have
happened to be there when the shooting
took place on the Gaza side he watched
he said as a group of young Palestinian
women stepped forward dark cloaks
colorful sneakers gesticulating wildly
and yelling this is our land it's not
yours suddenly two bullets slammed into
the ground in front of them kicking up
puffs of dust the crowd jolted the women
retreated about fifteen feet but two
minutes later they were moving forward
again taunting the soldiers another shot
rang out and this time one of the women
fell to the ground clutching her stomach
her name is Allah I sell theory
four days after she was shot she was
still waiting permission to see if she
could get to Israel for medical they get
they charge our border with the desire
with the stated goal of killing us and
then we she was on and we turn around
and offer the medical assistant I think
it's a vase the only reason she wasn't
admitted was because the Palestinian
Authority of Mahmoud Abbas cut off all
the payments in the but the only reason
that she wouldn't have been emitted and
the the New York Times journalist who
told the army spokesman of the incident
he gave the time and location text
message spokesman said he could find no
trace of the shooting he would continue
to inquire since then nothing but the
High Commissioner for Human Rights who
you don't think much of I do not he did
find her at the Shifa Hospital in Gaza
his bullet damage to her pancreas spleen
duodenum sustained at a distance of 350
meters from your border fence
according again to the High Commissioner
what fret was she at this
unknown at 350 meters from your border
if a sniper took aim at a woman who was
300 yards away and pull the trigger then
that sniper will have to answer for it
in a battlefield in a battle situation
bullets fly and they go far I know I've
been in the Army listened to very old
their answer every one of them every
single bullet every single bullet every
shot certainly one that hit it has to be
counted for they have and we have a very
specific record of every shot pagan and
and it will be investigating it you
couldn't find this one they could find
no no sign of the shooting having taken
place we haven't even think we haven't
even begun
all of these investigations these
investigations sometimes take months
they do that's the fact that you you as
a journalist might want a 24-hour
tournament doesn't work like that in
real life and you have to look at all
the films you have to look at at how
many bullets were fired by that
particular soldier and when and and the
and the chain of command it went through
because no fight no soldier fires at
will that order did not exist on the
Gadar border and it was within
international law yes according to our
military experts in our army yes and
that is what is being disputed I was
only being disputed by an organization
say by the UN High Commissioner or by oh
by France or by the EU very smooth the
human rights organization or by bet
Salaam or any or I'll argue in states of
Europe again an unhealthy obsession on
our part but a unhealthy ignorance of
what goes on elsewhere in the Arab world
or even what France did in fighting Isis
I don't see a tremendous amount of
introspection anywhere about or even a
questioning of calling to account of
thousands of Syrian and Iraqi civilians
killed in the war against Isis mr. Oren
let's talk about Iran you got you wish
Donald Trump pulled out of the nuclear
deal Mitch to the dislike of the
Europeans Russia China your Prime
Minister was warning of dire
consequences if the deal was allowed to
go through but your Prime Minister has a
history of predicting dire consequences
doesn't history be proved wrong
them doesn't he he's cried wolf so many
times look at look at Iraq 2002 he
memorably told the US Congress there was
no question whatsoever that Saddam
Hussein was advancing towards the
development of nuclear weapons if you
take out Saddam's regime he said I
guarantee you that it will have enormous
positive reverberations on the region
that were welded live yeah I also
testified in front of Congress against
the Iraq war that was a terrible idea
and came up from a lot of criticism at
the time it was a very popular in both
parties as clairvoyant abilities let's
talk about me there's a fight against
the Iran nuclear deal for close to a
decade I participated for five years and
the most intimate discussions with our
American allies about it I knew exactly
how they saw it and disagreed with it
profoundly and you disagree presumably
with your head of the army generalizing
cuts who said a couple of months ago the
deal with all its faults is working and
it's put it off realization of the
Iranian nuclear vision by 10 to 15 years
you disagreed with that as well no
actually I agree with it let me tell you
why I agree with it the danger was not
that Iran would violate the agreement
the danger was that Iran would keep the
agreement and the deal said the
following if Iran will agree to only
enrich enough highly enriched uranium to
weapons-grade for seven years at the end
of seven years it can begin enriching
enough highly enriched uranium for
dozens of bombs meanwhile they continued
with the missile development program
they kept all the blueprints for the
bomb
so it's brilliant why if you're an
Iranian that's getting paid tens of
billions of dollars for this deal and
using that money to spread terror to
conquer the Middle East why would you
not keep the DEA has confirmed that Iran
has complied with great it is dismantled
and removed two-thirds of its
centrifuges above par what's it this is
this is from Carmi Gillon who was one of
your Shin Bet where the it has reduced
its stockpile of enriched uranium has 98
percent shipping over twenty five
thousand pounds out of the country good
or bad
good good pretty good only good the coal
only good only good if the Iran deal
dealt with several issues one the
ballistic print the ballistic program
to the weaponization program and three
from my mind
it will equally paramount Iranian
behavior with Iran aspires to destroy my
state with Iran despise to take over the
Middle East to be the largest state
sponsor of terror that this agreement
didn't address in any way these issues
I'm sorry I don't have a I don't have a
more polite word it's insane probably
200 things it has done the core of its
Air Act are active reactor for instance
which could have allowed the country to
produce weapons-grade plutonium has been
removed and its shell filled with
concrete good or bad pretty good either
thought it's only for its good for
exactly seven years because one of the
things there's nothing in Poland of
course of course nothing other than
nothing so and you've offered nothing in
its place there's nothing in its true
there's nothing in its course daddy
what's plan B T is an agreement which
truly dismantled Iran's nuclear forget
that I can't predict the future but
there's certainly you know before erupt
for president Trump's withdrawal from
the treaty there was zero chance now
there is a chance well at least for 10
to 15 years something would have worked
and now there's nothing so for 10 15
years Iran gets to Massacre say a half a
million Syrians in the Syrian civil war
I know you don't care about that but
it's very close to here it's a two-hour
drive I don't know whether I care or not
you're not asking about you don't you
seem to think the Iran deal is deal
about Israel I'm asking you about Israel
because you neither represent Syria nor
Hamas Iran gets to establish itself
militarily in Syria and transform Syria
into an active military front against us
it gets to support tear around the world
to take over Yemen to take over Iraq to
fire missiles into Riyadh do you want to
have a war with Iran
oh we've for not to but we'll do
whatever we take what we need to defend
her so I think that that's true about
Gaza it's true about Iran stupid
anything sweetie 20 years he has spent
warning about Iran's nuclear bomb we
have just around the corner and now you
seem to want to make that into a
self-fulfilling prophecy but it won't be
and they won't dare because I didn't do
it before either because they know what
the consequences were here's the bottom
line we do want you want a bomb we ain't
about see anything that's gonna convince
you we didn't come to this building to
this kind
three to let you know your
garden-variety anti-semites destroy us
and we don't care if garden-variety
anti-semites in the world have a problem
with it
we're gonna do it we're gonna defend our
border in the south we're gonna defend
ourselves against Iran we're gonna
pursue our interest that's why we're
here that's why we have a sovereign
Jewish state Michael Oren good time
comes always thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]